Jakub PSX this week we got to see a lot
more Sony VR yes we did but not only did
they announce new games but they let us
try it the same day one of those games
was job simulator one of the stupidest
weirdest funniest games especially for
VR I've ever played yeah I think this
was I played a couple games there during
PSX and I think this is probably one of
my favorites just because it is just
ridiculous it's like all the kind of
stuff you want to do at work but you
can't well the concept of it is that
it's it's you're in the future and they
wanted people to know what it feels like
to go back in time and have a job like
it is today which is ridiculous and so
you put on this VR it's supposed to
simulate what life was like during this
time and it's so ridiculous like you
have standard things that you'd expect
in an office your computer your desks
there and there's you get some donuts
and a coffee coffee truck walks by but
it's so funny because you're you're also
using the Sony move peripherals and they
are so awkward and on purpose right this
is a surgeon simulator ass great you're
not meant to actually be able to do this
while picking up anything is a struggle
yeah I one of my favorite thing I mean I
just right off the bat I remember
starting I looked around and then I just
started throwing everything I could just
in the air and then people would lean
over the deaths a little robot
television things would lean over the
desk and they'd be like hey or what are
you doing and I'd start throwing
everything I could at them and they'd
get annoyed and and then and then the
guy was like you shouldn't make coffee
like alright I'll make coffee made the
coffee held it dumped it on my head and
then splashed the rest on my boss like
it was I mean it's just kind of a joke
but it's it's a fun joke like it's
something that I wanted to try again I
wanted to keep messing around with yeah
it's really silly and they not only did
they let you joke around with like the
food but you do you do feel it you feel
the immersion a little bit
when I was eating doughnuts I was
opening my mouth and like chewing and
making you sounds when I was eating it
and drinking the coffee but if we had so
much fun from just eating there was all
sorts of stuff you could touch in the
game there was a disc that if you put it
in it it played like flappy bird
knockoff of flappy bird and that was
silly its gimmicky if nothing else I'm
not sure of like the longevity of a game
like that yeah one thing though that I
did notice is it like I had a tough time
just not like walking around the office
like because you're kind of boxed in it
was constraining you probably on purpose
because it's just a demo right but at
the same time it was one of the most
memorable things I played at PSX and
more importantly I think it's one of the
most more memorable VR games that I've
played and when you think of what's
gonna make people want to buy VR it's
probably really stupid stuff like this
and 100-foot robot golfin you know
things that are absolutely ridiculous
but you could only enjoy that experience
in virtual reality
you